Paths and Functions
of Somatic Afferents
and Efferents of
the Head and Neck
Or... The Who,
The What, and
The Where of the
Cranial Nerve
Video 1. Cranial
Nerves 3, 4, and 6 This
material represents
a distillation of
information that can
be found in Moore's
Clinically Oriented
Anatomy, Chapters 8 and
10. For more specific
information about
each cranial nerve,
I recommend reading
chapter 8 and paying
close attention to
the blue boxes slash
blue pages as they
highlight the many
clinically relevant
aspects about this area
of cranial anatomy.
This lecture series
will cover 9 of the 12
cranial nerves. The
special afferents,
cranial nerves 1, 2,
and 8, will be covered
in a future lecture.
Throughout this
lecture, I will make
reference to the endocranium
and the skull as
separate structures.
The reason for
this is because the
hole a cranial
nerve uses to exit
the endocranium may
not always be the
same hole used to
exit the skull.
This will be made clearer
in this second video.
The first cranial nerve
that we will cover
today is cranial
nerve 3, oculomotor.
This is the major motor
nerve for the eye.
The oculomotor nerve
leaves the brain and
courses rostrally towards
the orbit. It runs
lateral to the cella
tercica and inside
the lateral wall of
the cavernous sinus.
The oculomotor nerve
exits the endocranium
via the superior
orbital fissure. After
exiting the endocranium,
oculomotor passes
through the common
tendinous ring. This
is where most of the
extraocular muscles
attach, and it is an
important anatomical
landmark for structures
within the orbit.
Past the ring, oculomotor
splits into two
major divisions, a
superior division and an
inferior division.
The superior division
innervates just two
muscles, the superior ******
and the levator palpebrae
superioris, a muscle
of the upper eyelid.
The inferior division
of oculomotor innervates
medial ******,
inferior ******, and the
inferior oblique. The
inferior division is
also responsible for
sending presynaptic
parasympathetic fibers to
the ciliary ganglion.
From this ganglion,
nerve fibers continue
into the eye as the short
ciliary nerves, where
they innervate the
ciliary body and sphincter
pupillae muscles.
Clinical correlate.
The multiple structures
innervated by oculomotor
can be used to
determine the location
of an oculomotor
lesion. For instance,
pitosis, or drooping
upper eyelid, is a
paralysis or weakness to
the levator palpebrae
superioris muscle.
Drooping eyelids
are a sign of
a lesion to the superior
division of the
oculomotor nerve.
In contrast, a
weakened medial ******
indicates a lesion to
the inferior division
of the nerve. A
complete lesion to
oculomotor results
in the signature down
-and-out presentation
of the affected
eye due to paralysis
of the four
extraocular muscles
controlled by the nerve.
Lastly, an inability
to constrict the eye
against light
suggests damage to the
parasympathetic fibers
traveling to the
sphincter pupillae
muscle, indicating a
potential lesion to
either the short ciliary
nerves or the ciliary
ganglion itself.
This is called anisocoria
and can best be
seen in famed rock legend
David Bowie. Moving
on to cranial nerve 4,
the trochlear nerve.
The trochlear nerve
is the smallest of our
cranial nerves and
is the only nerve to
leave the brain from
its dorsal surface.
All other cranial
nerves leave the
brain from the
ventral surface. From
the brain, the
trochlear nerve
follows the same path
as the oculomotor
nerve within the
cavernous sinus.
The trochlear nerve
passes superior
to the oculomotor
in the sinus
before exiting
the endocranium
through the superior
orbital fissure.
The trochlear nerve
innervates a single
extraocular muscle,
the superior oblique.
The superior oblique
follows a unique
path from the common
tendinous ring to reach
the posterolateral
aspect of the eye.
To accomplish this
feat, the muscle passes
a long tendon through
a fibrous loop that
juts out from the medial
wall of the orbit.
This loop creates
a pulley, which
in Latin is
called a trochlea,
hence where the trochlear
nerve gets its name.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the
trochlear nerve results
in weakness or
paralysis of the
superior oblique,
affecting the
ability to look down
or even straight.
Unopposed actions from
the inferior oblique
and superior ******
cause an upward
and inward deviation
to the affected eye.
The final cranial
nerve that we will be
looking at in this
video is cranial nerve
6, the abducens nerve.
The abducens, or
abducent nerve, leaves
the brain near the
pons medulla junction,
where it pierces the
dura mater near the
clivus of the skull.
From here, the nerve
crawls its way rostrally
towards the cavernous
sinus, following
the same general path
as both the trochlear
and oculomotor
nerve. The abducens
nerve lies furthest
medially within the
cavernous sinus before
it exits the endocranium
through the superior
orbital fissure.
Within the orbit, the
abducens nerve travels
straight to the
lateral ****** muscle,
the only muscle
innervated by this nerve.
Note the AB in abducens.
The name of the
nerve is based on the
function of lateral
******, which is
to abeduct the eye.
Clinical correlate.
Abducens nerve
lesions present as
a weakness or
paralysis of the
corresponding lateral
****** muscle.
The lack of antagonistic
action against
the medial ******
results in the affected
eye turning medially
towards the nose.
Abducens palsy is the
most common palsy of
the nerves that we
have looked at so far.
This is due to the more
medial location of the
abducens nerve within
the cavernous sinus.
This placement puts
the nerve closest
to the internal
carotid artery.
Blood clots in the
cavernous sinus, or
an aneurysm of the
internal carotid
within the sinus,
are more likely to
compress the abducens
nerve compared to
the other nerves
running in the sinus.
This brings us to
the end of video 1.
Paths and Functions
of Somatic
Afference and
Efference of the
Head and Neck.
Video number 2,
Cranial Nerves 5 and 7.
Okay,
strap in for
this one, folks.
Although this video
only covers two of
the 12 cranial nerves,
these two nerves have
the most complicated
distribution in
the head and neck, as
they are responsible
for most of the
innervation in the head.
We are only asking
you to remember a
fraction of the
myriad branches that
form from these
two cranial nerves.
Now, for your sanity
and mine, I highly
recommend that you
don't focus too
much on the course
that these nerves
take as they move
through the head.
Instead, for each
branch discussed,
try to answer these
three questions.
What root or division is
the nerve coming from?
What exit does
it use for the
endocranium
and the skull?
This can occasionally
have two answers to it.
What does the
nerve innervate?
Finally, for the
trigeminal nerve,
lean heavily on these
dermatome images
from Moore's clinically
-oriented anatomy.
Understanding this
distribution of trigeminal
across the face will
go a long way to
answering trigeminal
-focused questions.
Now that we've prepared,
it's time to get started.
Cranial Nerve
5 – Trigeminal
This is the largest
cranial nerve and is
responsible for most
of the sensation
to the head. The
name trigeminal is
derived from the Latin
word for triplet and
refers to the nerve's
unique branching
pattern off the
brain. The trigeminal
nerve originates
from the pons as a
collection of nerve
rootlets that travel a
short distance
anteriorly off the brain.
Most of these rootlets
enter a large ganglion
located lateral to
the cavernous sinus.
This is the
trigeminal ganglion.
Distal to the
trigeminal ganglion,
trigeminal
splits into three
different nerves
or divisions,
the triplets
of trigeminal.
These three big
divisions are
ophthalmic, maxillary,
and mandibular.
Also called cranial
nerves 5.1, 5.2, and
5.3, or as you will
likely hear in lab and
throughout your
career, V1, V2, and V3.
Let's take each
division one at a time.
Trigeminal 5
.1, ophthalmic.
This is the smallest
of the three divisions.
It arises from the
trigeminal ganglion
and follows a course
very similar to the
previous cranial nerves
discussed in video 1.
Ophthalmic travels
through the lateral wall
of the cavernous sinus
and exits the endocranium
through the superior
orbital fissure.
Ophthalmic comes from
the ancient Greek
word for the eye. The
name informs us about
what the nerve does
and where it goes.
Ophthalmic is a purely
sensory nerve. It
provides sensation to
the front of the face
above the eyebrows
and will send and
extensions posteriorly
to the occipital bone.
Once beyond the superior
orbital fissure,
the ophthalmic nerve
splits into three
nerves – frontal,
nasociliary, and lacrimal.
The frontal nerve
travels along
the roof of the
orbit and further
splits into two
terminal nerves.
The first nerve is the
supraorbital nerve.
It provides sensory
innervation to the skin
of the scalp, forehead,
and upper eyelid.
The supraorbital
nerve exits the
skull via the
supraorbital foramen or
supraorbital
notch, depending on
how well-developed
that opening is.
The second terminal
branch of the frontal
nerve is the
supratrochlear nerve. As
its name implies, the
nerve lies just above
the trochlea on the
medial wall of the
orbit. It exits the
skull via the medial
orbital rim and
provides sensory
innervation to the
midline of the brow ridge.
The next branch
from the ophthalmic
division is the
nasociliary nerve.
This nerve initially
follows the frontal
nerve before
splitting off to
travel inferior to
the optic nerve and
more anteromedially
through the orbit.
Here, it splits into
several terminal
branches.
Two of those branches
form the anterior
and posterior
ethmoidal nerves.
These go through the
medial wall of the
orbit to enter into
the ethmoid bone, where
they traverse the
nasal cavity and
paranasal sinuses, providing
sensory innervation
to the structures
in these regions.
Returning to the
nasociliary nerve,
as it passes over
the optic nerve, the
nasociliary nerve
sends off two or three
branches called the
long ciliary nerves.
These nerves provide
sensation to the
rest of the eyeball
and act as conduits
for sympathetic
nerve fibers coming
from the superior
cervical ganglion.
The final branch
of the nasociliary
nerve is the
infratrochlear nerve.
As its name implies,
infratrochlear travels
inferior to the trochlea
along the medial
wall of the orbit
before exiting the skull
via the medial
orbital rim to provide
cutaneous innervation
to most of the nose,
eyelids, and conjunctiva.
The final branch of
the ophthalmic division
is the lacrimal
nerve. This is the
smallest nerve off the
ophthalmic division and
is the only nerve that
travels laterally
after the trifurcation.
The lacrimal nerve
travels straight
to the lacrimal
gland in the
superolateral corner
of the orbital rim.
The lacrimal nerve
will provide sensory
innervation to the
lacrimal gland. I repeat,
sensory innervation.
The motor innervation
to the lacrimal gland
comes from elsewhere.
That covers the first
division of trigeminal.
Time to move on to the
next. cranial nerve
5-2, the maxillary. As
with ophthalmic, the
maxillary division
is entirely afferent.
However, unlike the
ophthalmic division, most
of the branches of the
maxillary division go
deep into the skull
and are very difficult
to see in a dissection.
The maxillary division
extends from the
trigeminal ganglion and
courses inferrorostrally
into the middle
cranial fossa, where it
exits the endocranium
via the foramen
rotundum. The maxillary
division sends out multiple
nerves to the head.
We will focus on just
five of these nerves.
The greater
palatine, the lesser
palatine, the
nasopalatine,
the zygomatic, and the
infraorbital nerve.
Shortly after entering
into the foramen
rotundum, the maxillary
division takes
two different paths
through the skull.
One path descends
the skull through an
opening called the
pterygopalatine fossa.
Within this fossa,
multiple branches
of the maxillary division
enter the
pterygopalatine ganglion.
This ganglion acts
as a junction between
the trigeminal
and facial nerves.
All of the trigeminal
fibers continue through
the ganglion without
synapsing. They exit
the pterygopalatine
ganglion as three different
terminal nerves. The
first two are the
greater and lesser
palatine nerves. They will
continue inferiorly
through the pterygopalatine
fossa until they exit
the skull through
the greater and lesser
palatine foramina.
The greater palatine
nerve conveys sensory
information from
the hard palate,
whereas the lesser
palatine nerve conveys
sensory information
from the soft palate.
The final terminal
nerve in this group
is the nasopalatine
nerve. This nerve
leaves the pterygopalatine
ganglion and
courses rostrally
into the nasal cavity.
Here, it provides
sensory innervation to
the lower half of
the nasal septum and
the mucosa along the
lateral nasal walls.
This nerve will
eventually exit the
skull through the
incisive canal, where
it provides sensory
innervation to the
rostralmost part
of the hard palate.
The second path
of the maxillary
division runs rosterally
from the foramen
rotundum into the
inferior orbital
fissure. Within this
fissure, the maxillary
division splits
into two nerves.
The first nerve is
the zygomatic nerve.
This nerve courses
along the lateral
wall of the orbit
and splits into
two terminal branches,
the zygomaticofacial
and zygomaticotemporal
nerves.
These two terminal
nerves will exit the
skull via foramina
of the same name and
go on to provide
sensory innervation to
their respective
portions of the head.
The second nerve to
branch within the
inferior orbital
fissure is the aptly
named infraorbital
nerve. The infraorbital
nerve courses
along the inferior
margin of the orbit
within a small
groove called the
infraorbital groove.
Along its course,
the infraorbital
nerve sends out
multiple small branches
into the maxillary
sinus and the
upper teeth. These
branches form
the anterior, middle,
and posterior,
superior alveolar
nerves. They provide
sensory innervation to
the teeth and gingiva
of the upper jaw.
The infraorbital
nerve eventually exits
the skull via the
infraorbital foramen.
Here, the nerve provides
sensory innervation
for the lower
eyelids, sides of the
nose, and upper lip.
That's two divisions
down, just one to go.
The third and
final division
of the trigeminal
nerve is the
mandibular
division, or 5-3.
This division of
trigeminal stands
apart from the rest
as it is the only
division that incorporates
a motor component.
The motor component
of the mandibular
nerve begins as
motor rootlets
leaving the pons.
These rootlets do not
pass through the
trigeminal ganglion.
Instead, they pass
inferior to the ganglion
in an area called
the trigeminal cave.
This makes the trigeminal
ganglion a solely
sensory ganglion.
Motor and sensory
components of 5-3 fuse
together past the trigeminal
ganglion to form the
mandibular division
of trigeminal, which
then quickly exits
the endocranium through
the foramen ovale.
The mandibular division
descends the skull
through the infratemporal
fossa. This is a
soft tissue space that
you will see in lab.
Within the fossa, the
mandibular division
quickly splits into
four sensory nerves,
the auriculotemporal,
the buccal, the lingual,
and the inferior
alveolar nerve. The
auriculotemporal nerve
provides sensation to
the ears and the temporal
region of the head.
The auriculotemporal
nerve is unique as
it forms from two separate
roots, the superior
and inferior root.
These roots pass around
the middle meningeal
artery before
anastomosing to form the
auriculotemporal nerve.
The buccal nerve, or
long buccal nerve,
splits off the mandibular
division and courses
rostrally through the
infratemporal fossa,
passing between both
heads of the lateral
pterygoid muscle.
The buccal nerve will
provide sensory
innervation to the mucous
membranes of the cheeks,
and may also send out
branches that provide
accessory sensory
innervation to the
second and third molars.
Do not confuse the
buccal nerve with
the buccal branch
of the facial
nerve, which we will
look at in a bit.
The buccal nerve is
strictly a sensory
nerve that has no
motor components.
The inferior alveolar
nerve is largely
a continuation of the
mandibular division
of trigeminal. It
descends through
the infratemporal
fossa and enters
the mandible at the
mandibular foramen.
From here, the nerve
courses through the
mandibular canal,
sending out multiple
branches to the teeth
of the mandible.
At the rostral, or
mesial, end of the
mandibular ramus,
the inferior alveolar
nerve exits the skull
through the mental
foramen. At this
foramen, we change the
name of the nerve
to the mental nerve.
The mental nerve
innervates the
skin of the chin
and lower lip.
The final sensory
branch of the
mandibular division
is the lingual nerve.
The lingual nerve branches
off the mandibular
division and runs
parallel to the inferior
alveolar nerve
through much of the
infratemporal fossa.
Near where the inferior
alveolar nerve enters
the mandibular foramen,
the lingual nerve
makes a sharp turn
rostromedially to enter
the oral cavity. Inside
the oral cavity, the
lingual nerve courses
into the tongue where
it provides somatic
sensory innervation to
the anterior two-thirds
of the tongue. That
covers the afferent
component of the
mandibular division of
trigeminal. Although the
motor component is the
smallest portion of the
mandibular division,
these motor actions
are very important.
This is because
the motor component
of the mandibular
division innervates
all of the muscles
of mastication.
These nerves are what
let us chew food.
There are five terminal
nerves of importance
for mastication.
Each nerve goes to
its respective
masticatory muscle, and
they are self
-explanatory. These nerves
are all named for
the muscles that they
innervate. The only
exception to this is
the nerve to
myelohyoid. This nerve
innervates both the
myelohyoid muscle and the
anterior belly of
the digastric muscle.
The nerve to
myelohyoid appears as a
split in the inferior
alveolar nerve just
before it enters the
mandibular foramen.
Whereas the inferior
alveolar nerve takes
an intraosseous
course through the
mandible, the nerve
to myelohyoid travels
externally along the
medial side of the
mandibular ramus to
reach its target muscles.
The complex interplay
between the various
muscles of mastication
and their firing
patterns is too detailed
for this video, or
frankly even a first
year of med school.
No, really, people
devote entire
careers to studying
chewing. For the
purposes of this course,
I would recommend
studying figure
8.72 in Mors and
reading the section
on mastication.
Along with that,
remember the
following pieces of
information. Temporalis,
masseter, and
medial pterygoid all
act as jaw closers.
Lateral pterygoid,
myelohyoid,
anterior digastric,
and gravity
all act to
open the mouth.
There are a few other
muscles that will also
act on the jaw, such
as the posterior belly
of digastric and
geniohyoid, but they are
not considered true
muscles of mastication.
We call these accessory
muscles of mastication
as it's gravity that's
doing most of the
work. The final two
branches of the mandibular
division of trigeminal
are the nerves
to tensor velle palatine
and tensor tympani.
Both nerves arise
from the otic ganglion
along with the nerve
to medial pterygoid.
The otic ganglion is
yet another ganglion
associated with the
trigeminal nerve, and
it is also yet another
ganglion that the
trigeminal nerve merely
passes through without
synapsing. The otic
ganglion is important
for the autonomics
of the face, which
will be dealt with in
a separate lecture.
The nerve to tensor
velle palatine innervates
the muscle of the
same name. This
muscle functions in
tensing the soft palate,
turning it from
a pliable surface
into a stiffened
board that could
be elevated as
a single unit,
allowing for proper
food swallowing.
We'll return to this in
more detail in video 3.
Importantly, the
tendon of tensor
velle palatine
also attaches to
the base of the
eustachian tube.
When tensor velle
palatine contracts,
it opens the
eustachian tube,
equalizing pressure
on the inside of
the ear, causing
your ears to pop.
The nerve to tensor
tympani travels
to the tensor
tympani muscle in the
ear. This is a
small muscle that
attaches to the
malleus, the ear ossicle
connected to the
tympanic membrane.
When tensor tympani
contracts, it stiffens
the tympanic membrane,
making it harder
for sound waves to
shake the ear ossicles,
resulting in dulled
sounds. Tensor tympani
activates in
response to very loud
sounds and functions
to shield the inner ear
from damage in high
-noise environments.
We will cover this
in more detail
in this special
afference lecture,
clinical correlate.
As the hub for somatic
sensory innervation
to the face, the
troubles with trigeminal
often present as pain
or numbness to portions
of the face. A common
clinical problem
associated with trigeminal
is trigeminal neuralgia,
otherwise known as
tic de la rue. This
is the result of
misfiring from one or more
sensory branches of
trigeminal on the face.
Patients come in
complaining of short
-lived but intense
stabbing pains on
their face in response
to anything from
a gentle touch to
a slight breeze.
Tic de la Rue has a
large impact on patient
quality of life, with
patients suffering
from it going to
great lengths to avoid
stimulating the affected
portion of their face.
The underlying
causes of Tic de la
Rue are variable
and mostly unknown.
Treatment varies from
local anesthetic to
partial or even complete
nerve resection.
Damage to the
motor component of
trigeminal often
manifests as
temporomandibular
joint or TMJ problems.
The proximal cause of
the patient's trouble
is usually the joint
itself, but the
underlying issues that
produce TMJ problems
in the first place
can be attributed to
misfiring of the
muscles of mastication,
which can misalign the
teeth, producing jaw
tenderness, tooth
damage, and headaches.
Wow,
okay. That will cover
all the important
branches of the
trigeminal nerve.
Awesome job making
it this far in.
It's time to take
a break. Get a good
stretch in, maybe
make a sandwich.
But before heading
off and preparing for
the facial nerve,
I want to briefly
look at this part of
the self-assessment.
See how you are asked
to diagrammatically
draw out the
branches of the
trigeminal nerve?
I recommend keeping
this part simple.
For instance,
let's draw the
branches of
the ophthalmic
real quick.
Here's the brain.
There's the trigeminal
ganglion. Off we
go to the frontal,
nasociliary and lacrimal
nerves. Off frontal
we'll add the
supraorbital and supratrochlear.
From nasociliary,
we'll toss in the
ethmoidal nerves,
long ciliary nerves,
and the infratrochlear
nerve. We can then
put some simple
brackets in for the
endocranium exits, some
nerve-specific notes
along the side, and
finally a note that
everything we just
did was for a nerve
that is only afferent.
Of course, you
don't have to do it
this way. Feel
free to choose the
drawing method that
works best for you.
Okay then,
quick break and
on to our last
cranial nerve.
Cranial nerve 7,
the facial nerve.
If the trigeminal
nerve is the main
afferent nerve
for the face, the
facial nerve is the
main motor nerve.
The facial nerve
innervates all of the
muscles of facial
expression, which are
about 20 or so. The
facial nerve also
innervates most of the
glands in your head.
Glandular innervation
is all autonomic
and so will be
covered in a separate
autonomics lecture. The
facial nerve starts as
two routes that
leave the junction of
the pons and medulla.
The larger route is
called the primary
route, or the facial
nerve proper. This
route innervates all
of the muscles of
facial expression. The
smaller route is
called the intermediate
route, or intermediate
nerve, as it is
the autonomic branch
of the facial nerve.
Shortly after leaving
the brain, both
routes quickly
combine to form the
facial nerve. The
newly formed nerve
travels laterally in
the posterior cranial
fossa before exiting
the endocranium
through the internal
acoustic meatus.
The facial nerve shares
this exit with the
vestibulocochlear
nerve, cranial nerve 8.
However, the facial
nerve is the only
nerve that will later
leave the skull.
Shortly after
entering the internal
acoustic meatus, the
facial nerve travels
posteriorly through
the walls of the middle
ear within the facial
canal. Now, this
gives the facial
nerve the longest
intraosseous course
of any cranial nerve.
The area where
the facial nerve
changes direction
is called the
geniculum of the
facial nerve.
Genu is Latin for
knee, and it is
here where the
facial nerve expands
into a ganglion
of nerve fibers
called the
geniculate ganglion.
The geniculate
ganglion is another
ganglion that will
be more important
to you later when
discussing the
autonomic component
of the facial nerve.
For the purposes of
this video, the ganglion
serves as a helpful
landmark to locate the
start of three
branches of the facial
nerve. The greater petrosal
nerve, a communicating
branch that will join
the lesser petrosal
nerve, and the external
petrosal nerve.
These three
nerves will send
autonomics from
the facial nerve to
various locations
in the head.
Beyond the geniculate
ganglion, the
facial nerve courses
around the tympanum,
making a C-shaped
curve around the
middle ear until
the nerve eventually
courses anteriorly
through the skull.
As the facial nerve
passes by our middle
ear ossicle, the
stapes, it will send
out a small branch
into the middle ear
cavity to innervate
the stapedius muscle.
As with tensor tympani,
the stapedius muscle
functions as a sound
dampener during times
of intense noise. We
will revisit stapedius
as well in the special
afference lecture.
Continuing antero
-inferiorly around the
middle ear, the
facial nerve sends out
another special branch
called cordotympani.
This nerve briefly
crosses through
the middle ear before
exiting the skull
through the petro
-tympanic fissure.
Cordotympani will
enter the infratemporal
fossa where it joins
with the lingual
nerve and rides that
nerve into the tongue.
We will return to
cordotympani in the
special afference
lecture as well.
The remaining
parts of the
facial nerve exit
the skull through
the stylomastoid foramen.
Immediately after
exiting the stylomastoid
foramen, the facial
nerve sends a branch
posteriorly to wrap
around the ear. This
is the posterior
auricular nerve. It will
innervate a vestigial
muscle of the ear
that pulls the ears
back in other animals.
Continuing antero
-inferiorly,
the facial nerve
sends out a
branch to the
digastric muscle.
This branch will
innervate the posterior
belly of the
digastric muscle. This
gives digastric dual
innervation. The
anterior belly receives
innervation from the
nerve to myelohyoid,
a branch of 5-3,
whereas the posterior
belly gets the
digastric branch of
the facial nerve. The
rest of the facial
nerve will continue
anteroinferiorly to
enter the parotid
gland where it explodes
out to form the
parotid plexus deep
within the gland.
Here, the facial
nerve splits out
into five different
motor branches.
These five branches
innervate all 20
or so facial muscles.
The five branches
of the parotid plexus
are named based
on where they are
going, but in a
generally superior to
inferior direction,
they are the
temporal, zygomatic,
buccal, marginal
mandibular, and
cervical branches
of the facial nerve.
A popular mnemonic
for remembering the
branches of the
facial nerve is To
Zanzibar by Motor Car
However, there are
dozens of alternative
mnemonics as
well, such as Tiny
Zebras Bit My Cheeks,
as well as several
dirtier versions
Now, the distribution
pattern of
the parotid plexus
that I've shown
here is a very
general pattern
Cadaveric studies
have found that
branching, or
arborization pattern, of
the parotid plexus
is highly variable
You will be tested
on this ideal version
I've shown here
for the purpose of
learning the
material, but don't be
surprised if the donors
in lab don't show
this same pattern
as few people will
have this exact
pattern in real life.
Of all the branches
of the parotid plexus,
the most important
one to understand
is the buccal branch
of the facial nerve.
This branch innervates
the buccinator muscle,
a facial muscle that
tenses the cheeks,
allowing for
suckling, *******,
whistling, brass
instrument playing, etc.
Do not confuse the buccal
branch of the facial
nerve with the buccal
nerve of trigeminal.
The former is the
motor innervation for
buccinator. The latter is
the sensory innervation
of the cheek mucosa.
When you suck your
cheeks into your mouth,
you are using the
buccal branch of facial.
When you feel the
pain of accidentally
biting those cheeks, you
are using the buccal
nerve from trigeminal.
Clinical correlate
The most common
clinical correlate
associated with
the facial nerve
is Bell's palsy.
This is the result
of a lesion to one or
more branches of the
parotid plexus, resulting
in partial to complete
paralysis of the
muscles of facial expression
on the ipsilateral
side of the face
where the lesion is.
Bell's palsy is often
idiopathic and temporary.
However, in some cases,
such as with Sylvester
Stallone, Bell's palsy
can be permanent.
In the case of Stallone,
his was acquired
during birth, where
labor complications
forced the doctor to
use forceps. In the
process, the doctor
accidentally damaged some
branches of his right
parotid plexus, producing
his characteristic
facial expression.
Congratulations on
surviving our whirlwind
tour of the two most
complicated cranial
nerves in the head.
It's time for a break.
This brings us to
the end of video two.
Paths and functions
of somatic afferents
and efferents of
the head and neck.
Video 3. Cranial nerves
9 through 12. This
is the final video
in the series and
will cover the remaining
cranial nerves.
As with video 2, I
recommend focusing
more on where the nerve
exits the endocranium
and skull and what
it innervates.
Cranial nerve 9. The
glossopharyngeal nerve.
nerve. This is the
main sensory nerve of
the pharynx, and is
responsible for both the
general and special
sense of taste for the
proximal one-third
of the tongue. The
glossopharyngeal nerve is
mostly a sensory nerve,
but it does contain a
single motor component
along with some autonomics.
This motor component
innervates the
stylopharyngeus muscle.
Glossopharyngeal leaves
the brain from the
medulla, where it exits
the endocranium and
the skull through the
jugular foramen. Just
inferior to the foramen,
the glossopharyngeal
nerve forms two
successive swellings, the
superior ganglion and
the inferior or petrous
ganglion. This is
where the afferent cell
bodies of the
glossopharyngeal nerve live.
Glossopharyngeal then
descends the neck,
running parallel to
the stylopharyngeus
muscle, sending branches
out to innervate
it as it goes.
Beyond stylopharyngeus,
the glossopharyngeal
nerve dives between
the superior
and middle pharyngeal
constrictor muscles,
sending out
multiple branches to
the pharyngeal plexus
as it descends.
These branches will
provide somatic sensory
information for
the entire pharynx.
Glossopharyngeal will
surface again on the
anterior side of the
pharyngeal constrictors,
where it terminates
in the posterior side
of the tongue,
innervating the proximal
one-third. The
glossopharyngeal nerve rarely
suffers damage and does
not really have any
common clinical
presentations associated
with it, so we'll move
on. The next nerve on
our tour is one that
we are all too familiar
with, cranial nerve
10, the vagus nerve.
Vagus comes from
the Latin word for
wandering or straying
and is a most apt
name for this cranial
nerve. The vagus
nerve is the only
cranial nerve to
extend beyond the head
and neck. The vagus
nerve serves as
the main carrier of
parasympathetic
innervation for the axial
region of the body,
sending branches as
far down as the first
two-thirds of the
transverse colon and
all of the kidneys.
There are even a
few branches that
sneak their way down
to the genitalia.
Vagus should be no
stranger to you at this
point, as we have
seen most of these
branches in previous
lectures and labs. For this
video, I'm only
going to focus on the
functions of vagus
within the head and neck.
The vagus nerve exits
the brain from the
medulla and travels
out the endocranium and
skull via the jugular
foramen. Similar to
the glossopharyngeal
nerve, the vagus
nerve will also form
two small swellings in
the jugular foramen, the
superior and inferior
ganglia of vagus. The
superior or jugular
ganglion is the
afferent component of
vagus, whereas the
inferior or nodos ganglion
handles the autonomic
motor functions.
In the head and neck,
there are just three
major branches of
the vagus nerve. The
pharyngeal branch,
the superior laryngeal
nerve, and the recurrent
laryngeal nerve.
The pharyngeal branch
is the first to
come off vagus and joins
with glossopharyngeal
to complete the
pharyngeal plexus.
Glossopharyngeal
provides the sensory
innervation, whereas the
pharyngeal branch provides
the motor to the three
pharyngeal constrictor
muscles. The
pharyngeal branch also
innervates all of the
muscles of the soft palate
except for tensor
velae palatini, which,
as we learned in video
2, receives innervation
from 5-3. The final
muscle innervated by
the pharyngeal branch
is the palatoglossus
muscle of the tongue.
The superior laryngeal
nerve is the next to
branch off vagus as it
descends the neck. This
nerve travels antero
-inferiorly to reach
the superior portion
of the larynx. As it
travels, it divides into
two smaller branches,
the internal and
external laryngeal nerves.
The internal laryngeal
nerve is the larger
of the two terminal
nerves. It is a sensory
nerve that provides
innervation for the
mucous membranes of the
laryngeal vestibule
and middle cavity,
including the vocal folds.
It will also send out
a branch to innervate
a small portion of the
tongue. The external
laryngeal nerve is
smaller than the internal
and is a strictly
motor nerve. It provides
motor innervation to
the inferior laryngeal
constrictor muscle
and sends another motor
branch to the cricothyroid
muscle of the larynx,
innervating it.
Note that cricothyroid
is the only
intrinsic laryngeal
muscle to be innervated
by the superior
laryngeal nerve. After
sending off the
superior laryngeal
nerve, vagus continues
to descend the neck
without sending any
further branches.
Once inside the thorax,
the vagus nerve sends
out one final branch
to the neck. This
branch loops back up
into the neck from the
thorax. It is the
recurrent laryngeal nerve.
Remember, the recurrent
laryngeal nerve
is asymmetrical
in where it loops
back. The left side
goes around the
arch of the aorta
near the ligamentum
arteriosum, whereas
the right side wraps
around the right
subclavian artery.
Both recurrent
laryngeal nerves travel
superiorly next to
the trachea in an area
called the
tracheoesophageal groove.
The recurrent
laryngeal nerves will
give off small
sensory branches along
the way, providing
sensory innervation
for the trachea
and esophagus.
The recurrent laryngeal
nerve ends when
it reaches the larynx.
Here, we change
the name to the inferior
laryngeal nerve.
The inferior laryngeal
nerve is the major
nerve supply for
the larynx. It has a
sensory component that
provides sensation
to the inferior
glottic cavity, and a
motor component that
handles all of the
other intrinsic
muscles of the larynx.
There are two branches
of the internal
laryngeal nerve. The
anterior branch supplies
most of our laryngeal
muscles, and the
posterior branch
supplies the remaining.
You will not be
asked to specifically
identify which branch
innervates which muscle.
Just remember that
the inferior laryngeal
nerve is the major
innovation for
these intrinsic
laryngeal muscles and
that cricothyroid is
the sole exception.
There are nine
pairs of laryngeal
muscles that move
the laryngeal
cartilages in
different ways.
Figure 9.39 from
Moore's offers a nice
summary of how these
muscles work. The
two most important
pieces of information
to learn at this
stage are that the
posterior cricoarytenoid
muscles are the
only muscles that
abduct the vocal folds
and that the cricothyroid
muscle is the
only intrinsic
laryngeal muscle not
innervated by the
inferior laryngeal nerve.
Lunachocorrelate
Damage to the recurrent
laryngeal nerve
happens during
surgical accidents
or as a consequence
of enlarged thyroid
tumors and aneurysms
of the aorta or
subclavian artery.
A lesion of the
recurrent laryngeal nerve
results in partial
or total paralysis
to most of the
intrinsic muscles of the
larynx. If the damage
is unilateral, the
patient will present
with what sounds
like a hoarse throat.
If the damage is
bilateral, then complete
mutinous results.
Bilateral paralysis
of the laryngeal
muscles leads to
difficulty breathing as
the vocal folds are
now not able to fully
abduct, resulting
in raspy breathing.
The next nerve that
we will look at is
cranial nerve 11, the
spinal accessory nerve.
Unlike the rest of the
cranial nerves, the
spinal accessory nerve
starts outside of
the skull within the
spine. Hence the name.
It begins as a
collection of rootlets
from the first five
to six cervical
segments of the spinal
cord. These rootlets
enter the skull
through the foramen
magnum. Once inside
the endocranium, the
fully formed nerve
will run together
with vagus as they both
exit the endocranium
and skull via the
jugular foramen.
From here, the spinal
accessory nerve
parts ways with vagus
and goes inferiorly,
paralleling the
internal carotid artery
before splitting
off to innervate the
sternocleidomastoid
and trapezius muscles.
These two muscles were
once a single, large
back muscle that can
still be seen in fish.
The evolution of
necks in land animals
required the head to
move separately from the
body, necessitating
the splitting of this
large back muscle into
two smaller muscles.
The shared innervation
from the spinal
accessory nerve is a
hallmark of that origin.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the spinal
accessory nerve
is often the result
of an accident,
such as whiplash
from an automotive
collision or laceration
during surgery.
Lesions to the spinal
accessory nerve produce
weakness of the
trapezius, causing the
shoulders to droop
towards the affected side.
Spinal accessory lesions
can also occur during
childbirth if the
birthing process is
particularly difficult.
This results in
torticollis, or an abnormal
twisting of the neck,
caused by an entrapped
or shortening of the
sternocleidomastoid
muscle fibers. An acquired
form of torticollis,
known as spasmodic
torticollis, occurs
when a damaged cranial
nerve 11 becomes
hyperactive, causing the
sternocleidomastoid to
consistently contract.
In all of these
cases, the head will
tilt towards the
affected side
while the face
points away from it.
The final cranial
nerve in this series
is cranial nerve
12, the hypoglossal
nerve. This is the
chief motor supply
for most of the
muscles of the tongue.
Hypoglossal leaves
the brain near the
medulla and exits
the endocranium and
skull through the
hypoglossal canal.
After exiting the
skull, the hypoglossal
nerve initially
descends the neck before
changing direction
and moving anteriorly,
where it passes between
the internal carotid
artery and the
internal jugular vein.
As hypoglossal does
this, it picks up a
few hitchhikers from
the cervical plexus.
These nerve fibers
are conveyed to their
destination in the
superior root of ansa
cervicalis via the
hypoglossal nerve, despite
not actually being part
of the nerve itself.
Once hypoglossal
reaches the posterior
belly of digastric,
these hitchhiking nerve
fibers split off and
continue inferiorly
towards the
anticervicalis. At this
point, the hypoglossal
nerve changes
direction once more and
runs superiorly into
the base of the
tongue, where it fans
out to innervate all
of the tongue muscles,
with the exception
of palatoglossus.
Our tongue has
intrinsic muscles and
extrinsic muscles.
The intrinsic muscles
are hard to differentiate
in lab and are
deep within the
tongue. The comparisons
we care most about
are in regards to the
extrinsic muscles.
If the name ends in
glossus, it's an
extrinsic tongue muscle,
which means that
it attaches to the
tongue from somewhere
else on the body.
Genioglossus is the
large fan-shaped
muscle of the
tongue. It's the
most easily seen,
and it functions to
extend the tongue
from the mouth.
Hyoglossus does
the opposite,
retracting the tongue
and depressing it.
Styloglossus also
retracts the tongue,
but it will
elevate it as well.
So too will
palatoglossus.
Remember that
palatoglossus is the
only extrinsic
tongue muscle that
is not innervated
by hypoglossal.
Palatoglossus is
innervated by vagus.
The palate and tongue
are areas where
knowing which muscle
is innervated by
which nerve can get
a bit confusing.
To alleviate this,
Jack Stern from
Stony Brook University
came up with
a simple nesting
doll approach
that we now refer
to as Stern's Law.
The concept is
simple. If a muscle
has tensor in the
name, it is innervated
by cranial nerve
5-3, full stop.
If the muscle has
palate in the name, it
is innervated by
cranial nerve 10, unless
tensor is in the name
2. If the muscle has
glossus in the name,
it is innervated by
cranial nerve 12, unless
palate is present.
Each new rule
is superseded
by the rule before it.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the hypoglossal
nerve presents
as weakness or paralysis
of tongue motions.
The geneoglossus
test is the
simplest way of
determining if
hypoglossal has
been damaged.
Geneoglossus is
a paired muscle,
and each side
receives innervation
from only one
hypoglossal nerve.
To test for a lesion
of the hypoglossal
nerve, patients are
asked to stick out
their tongue as
straight as they can,
activating their
genioglossus muscles.
If the nerve has
been damaged,
weakness or even
paralysis of
genioglossus will
cause the tongue to
deviate towards
the affected side.
We have just
learned about each
cranial nerve
in isolation.
However,
most head and neck
functions rely on
multiple cranial nerves
working in concert
with each other to
properly function.
let's briefly look at
two examples the gag
reflex this is a reflex
arc that keeps the
body from accidentally
ingesting an unexpected
food item it starts
when an unexpected
object comes into
contact with the back
of the pharynx this
triggers the afferent
limb of the gag reflex
which comes from the
glossopharyngeal nerve
in the pharyngeal
plexus glossopharyngeal
sends its afferent
signal back to a
specific nucleus in the
medulla, and this nucleus
communicates with an
adjacent nucleus that
sends a motor signal
via the vagus nerve,
triggering reverse
peristalsis, resulting
in the forceful expulsion
of the unexpected
object, or gagging.
Now, these are
the two big
nerves involved
with this reflex.
However, the reflex arc
may also incorporate
other nerves, such
as the mandibular
division of trigeminal
and hypoglossal,
opening the mouth and
lowering the tongue,
allowing for a
more efficient and
exaggerated expulsion
of the offending object.
Sensitivity and
contributions to the gag
reflex vary from person
to person, but it
does remain consistent
for any one person.
The gag reflex may
also just be missing.
Around 37% of
individuals do not
show an appreciable
gag reflex.
So that's one
example of multiple
nerves functioning
together.
Let's do one
more. This one
is a bit more
complicated.
Proper swallowing
or deglutition
requires the
precise coordination
of multiple
cranial nerves.
Deglutition is a
three-stage process.
The first stage takes
that food bolus and
pushes it to the back
of the mouth. This
is practically all
performed by our
tongue. The tongue
pushes and moves the food
item from the hard
to the soft palate,
bringing it to the
back of the throat.
This is a hypoglossal
dominant action.
The second stage is
the most complex.
Here we are taking
that food bolus and
dropping it into the
pharynx. To do this,
we need to get the
soft palate out of
the way. This is
accomplished via the
coordinated action
between the vagus nerve
and the mandibular
branch of trigeminal
via the nerve to
tensor velli palatini.
With the soft palate
out of the way, we
now have to widen
the pharynx. This is
done by activating
the longitudinal
muscles of the pharynx,
stylopharyngeus,
salpingopharyngeus,
and palatopharyngeus.
This requires activation
of our glossopharyngeal
and vagus nerves. As
these muscles lift
the larynx superiorly,
the epiglottis is
pushed closed over the
glottis, shutting off
our airway and preventing
us from choking.
The food can now
fall into the throat.
Our final stage
of deglutition is
the rhythmic
contraction of our
pharyngeal constrictors
as they push the
food bolus down
into the esophagus.
This peristaltic
action is done via
innervation from the
vagus nerve again.
So to summarize,
stage 1 is
hypoglossal dominant.
Stage 2, that's
the complicated
one. It involves
trigeminal,
glossopharyngeal,
and vagus.
Stage 3, that's
vagus dominant.
All these nerves must
function properly
for rhythmic
swallowing to occur.
The misfiring of
one or more of these
nerves produces
dysphagia, or
trouble swallowing,
as we can see here.
And with that,
we come to the
end of this video
lecture series.